We have seen how P Threads serve as an API for for the development of
parallel programs. For distributed programs, sockets serves as an
API for application development. And conventional distributor programming
such as NFS servers and so on use socket API
And build RPC packets on top of that. But unfortunately socket API
is too low-level and insufficient in semantic richness for emerging
multimedia distributed applications. Similarly sockets serve
as the API for distributed program development. So conventional distributed
programs are built using socket API, for example you man have a server
like an NFS server, and clients connect to
an NFS server using sockets, in order to do the
distributed I/O between the client and the server. But unfortunately,
socket API is too low-level, and it doesn't have the semantic richness
that is needed for emerging novel multimedia distributed applications.